Speaker 1: Yesterday morning, the Ukrainian
president, Volodymyr Zelensky, spoke
to a not really a joint session, but members
of both the U.S. House and the U.S. Senate
and made a number of requests in that speech,
including that the United States put in place
and enforce a no fly zone over Ukraine, which
is. The enforcement of a no fly zone is a
significant escalation and significant American
involvement, and asked for a number of additional
weapons systems and additional armaments and
supplies, and indeed, later in the day. Yesterday,
President Joe Biden announced an additional
$800 million in military assistance to Ukraine,
including drones and air defense systems. Now
we're going to go through the politics of it,
and we're going to go through the hypocritical
reactions to it. But let's first listen to Joe
Biden making this announcement yesterday.
Speaker 2: It'll include 7000 small arms
machine guns, shotguns, grenade launchers
to equip Ukrainians, including the brave
women and men who are defending their cities as
civilians and their on the countryside as well.
And we're and we're and as well as the
ammunition, artillery and mortar rounds
to go with small arms 20 million rounds in total,
20 million rounds. This will include drones,
which which demonstrates our commitment to sending
our most cutting edge systems to Ukraine first.
Speaker 1: So sending drones is quite a big deal.
The breakdown of the $800 million package is
800 Stinger anti-aircraft systems, 2000
Javelin, a thousand light anti-armor weapons
and 6000 84 anti armor systems, 100
tactical unmanned aerial systems,
drones, 100 grenade launchers, 5000 rifles,
1000 pistols, machine guns, shotguns,
20 million rounds, 25000 sets of body armor and
25000 helmets. Now there's a bunch of different
things to talk about here, first and foremost.
Isn't it weird that Joe Biden didn't say,
but I need you to do me a favor, though, before
sending this stuff OK? That's a joke. But in
all seriousness, the people on the right, the
Trumpists now criticizing Joe Biden for doing this
are the same people cheering and agreeing with
Trump that he armed Ukraine when he was president.
Despite the fact that Trump withheld
the aid trying to strong arm Zelensky
into announcing an investigation into Joe
Biden and ultimately was sort of forced
as it were to release the military aid because
of what we learned about him trying to hold host